by contacts établis en grève
et 3 2 aux parents
vous êtes qui vous tend frangin ça m'a
pris 28 ans mais s'était retrouvé au bon
dieu s'était pas occupé j'espère ce
virus tueur à un milliard de personnes
nous devons l'arrêté ton frère a besoin
de toi pour sauver le monde
nom de dieu
séduire la gent en robe verte tu ne peux
pas la rater elle est canon l île tracas
non on ne vous a jamais dit que c'est
une femme extrêmement motivante
si un jour un client mais c'est bill
cosby à la capelle elle dirige la plus
grande organisation criminelle au monde
c'est la patronne de la fifa tuer ces
crétins cette flèche est contient une
toxine mon seul espoir est que tu suces
absolument hors de question
tu peux arrêter de tirer sur tout ce qui
bouge
tellement mon dieu je suis la saisie de
sharon stone dans basic instinct à la
mairie